Transcription: Kendehl Taylor
Relecteur: Anne-Sophie Matichard
Ça va venir toucher à votre créativité,
parce que vous consommez tellement
de contenu que vous n’êtes plus productif.
Vous avez tout vu, mais qu’en est-il
du taux de productivité ?
Tout simplement parce qu’avec le téléphone
entre les mains,
je ne peux rien faire.
Je ne peux rien faire parce que
la productivité est en baisse constante.
J’ai donc décidé de laisser de côté
mon téléphone pendant quelques heures
et m’occuper à faire autre chose,
comme la cuisine.
Mais en cuisine, il fallait que je filme
pour mes abonnés.
Il fallait que je crée du contenu.
J’ai quand même essayé d’avoir
des moments sans mon téléphone
parce que pendant le COVID,
il n’y avait pas grand chose à faire.
Lire - ce que je fais tout le temps,
mais actuellement,
je le fais sur mon téléphone.
J’écoute les livres audio parce que
je n’ai pas le temps de prendre un livre ;
c’est dommage parce que je sais
que je peux consacrer encore
du temps à la lecture.
Le sport - quand on fait du sport,
on ne va pas avoir son téléphone
pour écouter de la musique.
Ce n'est pas grave.
Il y a des activités qui me permettent
d’avoir les mains occupées
et qui nécessitent de la concentration,
tel le sport, comme je viens de l’évoquer.
Je suis ensuite passée à l’étape suivante,
qui est de faire une pause de 24 heures :
ne rien poster sur mes réseaux
et ne pas consulter les notifications,
ce qui peut être difficile pour les gens
qui attendent des messages,
et qui ont cette addiction comme moi.
Et je pense que beaucoup de personnes
ont cette addiction.
Donc je le fais généralement le dimanche
puisque c’est plus simple,
notamment par rapport aux emails
parce qu’un collaborateur ne va pas
envoyer un email le dimanche.
Ça peut arriver,
mais je garde le dimanche pour moi,
pour sortir, pour passer des moments
en famille
et je réponds à mes partenaires
dans la semaine,
en toute logique, le lundi.
Donc cette expérience de pause
me redonne de la motivation
et me rend les idées plus claires
à chaque fois.
C’est magique.
À chaque fois que je m’éloigne
de mon téléphone,
je me sens libre
et beaucoup plus efficace.
Parfois, j’ai l’impression que
si je consomme beaucoup de contenu,
ça va me permettre d’acquérir
plus de créativité.
Mais en fin de compte,
je consomme tellement de contenu
que j’ai l’impression que j’ai tout vu
et que je ne peux plus rien faire.
(Rires)
Je vous recommande vivement
le livre de Cal Newport :
« Réussir (sa vie) grâce au
minimalisme digital ».
Je crois très fortement au minimalisme.
Ça m’a beaucoup aidée pour faire la détox,
que ce soit dans ma vie,
que ce soit chez moi,
mais ça, c’est un autre sujet dont
on pourra parler une prochaine fois.
Le livre traite du minimalisme digital,
c’est-à-dire tout
cet encombrement numérique
qui s’acharne sur nous
et qui nous déstabilise
à chaque fois qu’on reçoit
une nouvelle notification.
Comment on va soigner ce rapport
avec le smartphone ou l’ordinateur?
Donc, sachez qu’on a tous
des mentalités différentes,
et j’y crois fortement,
on a tous des visions divergentes,
des occupations et
des centres d’intérêts différents.
On veut tous réussir dans la vie,
comme notre idole,
comme notre CEO préféré,
d’ailleurs ils ne sont pas connectés
H24 sur leur téléphone.
Et on veut s'inspirer d'eux.
Sauf qu’eux, ils ne font pas
les mêmes choses.
Donc pour générer de l’argent
ou développer son business,
c’est bien d’être connecté,
d’avoir une idée de ce qui se passe
dans le monde,
mais il ne faut pas s’y noyer.
Donc j’espère que c’est clair.
Je ne voudrais pas oublier les points
que je voulais citer,
c’est important de rester organisé.
Ce n'est pas possible de rester
collé devant son écran H24.
Ce que je ne réussis pas
à faire actuellement,
sauf quand je décide de faire une détox,
c’est-à-dire aujourd’hui,
je ne vais pas toucher à mon téléphone,
je le laisse chez moi et je sors.
Si c’est pour des appels urgents,
je prends le petit téléphone
sur lequel il n’y a pas d’applications.
Il n’y a ni Facebook, ni Instagram ;
juste les appels urgents.
Donc je reste collée à mon téléphone
ou à mon ordinateur -
même si j’ai du travail sur l’ordinateur,
je vais sur YouTube pour voir des vidéos
et rester collée pendant des heures
devant des compilations, des vidéos.
Parfois pour suivre des événements,
des bagarres virtuelles, des futilités.
Et ça, ça dévore énormément de mon temps
et je sais - je parle pour moi -
que c’est le cas de beaucoup de personnes.
Sauf que je ne veux pas parler
à votre place.
Je sais que la majorité de personnes
souffrent de ça,
et je me dis que je suis
quand même chanceuse
parce qu’au lieu de juste consommer
le contenu d’Internet,
j’essaye d’être créatrice de contenu
pour pouvoir retirer quelque chose
de ce temps que je passe sur les réseaux.
Donc, vous savez bien que
c’est très simple, c’est très facile,
il n’y a rien de plus facile que de passer
7 heures sur YouTube à regarder des vidéos
ou sur Instagram, Facebook.
Et c’est très, très difficile de passer
une heure à travailler
ou d’écrire un article que
vous devez vraiment écrire.
C’est normal parce que le cerveau
choisit la facilité,
et c’est la raison pour laquelle
on choisit des contenus très simples,
pas de jeux difficiles.
Mais quand on redevient conscient
de notre situation actuelle,
on se plaint du manque de temps,
alors on reprend le contrôle de nos vies
à travers cette démarche intelligente
qui est de faire une détox :
lorsqu’on se sent trop absorbé
par tout cela,
il faut en sortir en faisant
une petite détox
pour ne pas trop être noyé
par les réseaux.
Il faut savoir que l’addiction à l’écran
crée un manque de concentration,
surtout pour les gens qui ont un travail
qui nécessite énormément de concentration,
et le fait de rester figé sur son écran
fait perdre la concentration
et c’est une chose dont
la majorité des jeunes souffrent.
C’est le manque de concentration
et ce n’est pas facile
de retrouver cette capacité,
puisque à chaque petite seconde de vide,
on prend le téléphone.
Si je n’ai pas compris un mot
ou quelque chose sur mon ordinateur,
je vais voir sur mon téléphone et ça fait
apparaître le fil Instagram ou Facebook.
Heureusement j’ai pas Facebook,
sinon j’aurais passé 20 heures
sur mon téléphone.
Alors à ces moments-là,
il faut essayer de revenir sur terre
et reprendre le travail à chaque fois
qu’on est envahi par les notifications.
Il y a des personnes qui rencontrent
des troubles de l’estime de soi,
et je reçois énormément de messages
de la part de personnes qui me disent :
« Zozi, je me compare trop aux autres. »
C’est un aveu :
« Je me compare trop aux autres
car je suis trop sur mon téléphone »
et je ne comprenais pas ça.
Pourquoi se comparer aux autres  ?
Il faut tracer sa vie selon
son propre référentiel.
Mais par la suite, je les ai compris,
parce que je consommais énormément
de contenu et je commençais à me comparer,
pas pour me comparer avec
le physique des autres,
mais je comparais le niveau
de mon travail à celui des autres.
Je me disais : « Il a réussi à faire ça,
moi, je n’ai pas encore réussi. »
Pas par jalousie ;
c’est juste le fait de voir que les autres
font des choses
et que moi, je ne les fais pas.
Alors que si j’y pense vraiment,
je me rends compte que moi aussi,
je fais des efforts ; moi aussi j’avance.
Mais à force de voir les autres,
j’ai l’impression qu’ils sont meilleurs,
qu’ils me dépassent.
Ce qui est très malsain
comme façon de voir les choses.
Et d’ailleurs, on n’a aucune idée
de la réalité des autres,
à part les quelques secondes
qu’ils nous offrent,
des photos retouchées
qui ne reflètent pas du tout la réalité.
Il y a des réalités qui sont retouchées,
d’autres qui ne le sont pas.
Mais on ne peut pas juger la réalité
des autres sur 15 secondes de leur vie,
ou sur une quinzaine de minutes
avec une série de stories.
Je vous conseille donc
vivement de penser au minimalisme digital,
j’y reviens à chaque fois,
j’en parle à chaque fois
parce que c’est une étape
de faire le tri.
Par exemple, sur mon ordinateur,
il n’y a pas beaucoup de fenêtres,
pas beaucoup de photos.
Je supprime tout ce qui est inutile
et ça m’aide énormément
pour ne pas me plonger dans
des histoires encore plus profondes
que celles de YouTube et Instagram.
Ça me permet de gagner plus d’espace
de stockage, ce qui est bien,
et en même temps, ça me permet
de ne pas être distraite
par toutes les notifications
des autres applications inutiles.
D’ailleurs, j’ai des notifications
d’applications qui s’ajoutent
à mon ordinateur et qui ne servent à rien
et qui me font perdre du temps.
Beaucoup de personnes
ont des applications
qu’ils n’utilisent jamais.
Et je vois ça sur les téléphones
de mes amis : beaucoup d’applications.
Pour des raisons de stockage,
je ne garde que les applications
qui me servent,
comme l’application de transport,
la banque, Instagram, les emails
et les applications pour  les photos,
les retouches,
tout ce que j’utilise au quotidien.
Pour le reste, soit je désactive
les notifications,
soit je supprime l’application,
ce qui m’aide un peu.
C’est une façon pour ne pas
être désordonné :
c’est comme notre petite maison,
parce qu’on est tout le temps
sur le téléphone.
C’est votre petite maison,
c’est un petit chez vous.
Il faut donc l’organiser aussi
et ne pas être distrait.
Alors en tant que créatrice de contenu,
je ne peux pas supprimer
les réseaux sociaux
comme le font certaines personnes qui
suppriment les réseaux sociaux.
Je ne peux pas faire ça,
malheureusement ;
ce qui est bien,
mais j’ai des engagements à respecter,
et aussi une présence permanente
pour élargir ma communauté
et toucher un grand nombre de personnes.
C’est un travail au quotidien.
C’est un travail énorme,
même s’il y a des personnes qui n’arrivent
toujours pas à voir à quel point
ça prend beaucoup de temps,
mais ça va venir.
Avec le temps, les gens comprendront
que c’est un travail à temps plein
que de vouloir toucher
beaucoup plus de personnes, etc.
Et ce n'est pas du tout facile.
Le partage et la création
me fatiguent, c’est vrai,
mais j’aime beaucoup ce que je fais,
donc je ne pense pas que c’est
un travail qui s’acharne sur moi,
mais c’est plutôt le fait de faire défiler
le fil d’actualité sans raison.
C’est ça qui m’énerve.
Je ne devais pas utiliser ce terme,
mais ça m’énerve vraiment.
Parfois, je me retrouve à passer
une heure sur mon téléphone,
sans rien avoir fait, sans rien
avoir appris, sans avoir rien retiré,
et ça me frustre parfois.
C’est bien de s’inspirer et d’apprendre
de nouvelles choses grâce aux autres.
Mais le problème, c’est le temps
que nous prenons
pour trainer sur les réseaux sociaux
et devant l’écran.
Et ça affaiblit l’activité du cerveau.
Ça ne rend pas du tout créatif,
pas du tout productif.
Et à la fin de la journée,
ça rend un peu anxieux.
Personnellement, quand je sens
que je n’ai pas fait grand-chose,
ça me rend triste.
Je n’aime pas ne pas être productive.
Je me sens coupable quand
je ne fais pas beaucoup d’efforts.
Alors mon conseil,
peut-être que certaines personnes
ne le savent pas,
mais vous pouvez aller dans les paramètres
de votre Instagram,
puis sur « Mon activité ».
Ensuite, vous cliquez sur le temps d’écran
puis sur « Définir un rappel quotidien »
pour fixer une durée.
Avant, j’avais fixé une durée
de 30 minutes
et à chaque fois que je dépassais
les 30 minutes,
l’application m’envoyait
une notification pour que j’arrête.
Sauf que je la désactivais à chaque fois
parce que 30 minutes,
ce n’était pas suffisant.
Une heure, ce n'était pas suffisant.
Deux heures, ce n’était pas suffisant.
Donc je l’ai malheureusement désactivée.
J’essaie de me contrôler par moi-même.
Mais si vous n’êtes pas engagé
envers une communauté
ou vers des partenaires
ou des collaborateurs,
vous pouvez quand même
fixer une heure,
deux heures, trente minutes,
comme vous voulez.
Comme ça, vous avez au moins ce rappel.
Vous pouvez également faire ça avec
les paramètres de votre téléphone.
Sur mon téléphone, il y a la possibilité
de diminuer le temps d’écran.
Le rappel va venir vous faire
un petit « ding » dans la tête :
« Ah non, je dois arrêter. »
Parfois, je décide de ne pas
faire attention au rappel.
Essayez ensuite de faire
une pause d’une demi-journée,
pour les gens qui n’arrivent pas du tout
à faire 24 heures sans réseaux sociaux.
Mais j’essaie quand même
de faire une demi-journée,
ou bien quatre, cinq heures,
sans le téléphone.
Ça fait tellement du bien.
Et pour donner du temps à ma famille,
à mes proches, à moi-même,
parce que ça fait tellement du bien
de se retrouver avec soi-même,
d’écouter de la musique
sans pour autant être envahi
par un milliard d’informations
par seconde.
Et le simple fait de se reconnecter avec
le monde réel, c'est un remède immédiat.
Quand je me sens anxieuse
et que j’arrête le téléphone,
j’ai l’impression que je suis guérie.
De quoi ? Je ne sais pas.
Je pense que la tonne d’informations
et de données par minute,
c’est énorme.
Donc ça peut sembler difficile au début
pour les gens qui sont vraiment accros.
Mais par la suite, vous allez comprendre
que ce n’est pas la fin du monde,
que c’est possible de ne pas
vérifier ses messages.
On ne va pas en mourir.
(Rires)
Alors maintenant, ce qui est important,
c’est de penser au retour
sur les réseaux sociaux ;
c’est-à-dire, je me suis arrêtée,
je ne me suis pas connectée
pendant 24 heures.
J’ai essayé de faire une détox, une pause.
J'ai vraiment suivi tous les conseils.
Je n’ai pas été envahie par
un milliard de notifications.
Mais il faut bien filtrer les gens
que vous suivez au quotidien,
parce que les gens que vous suivez
ne vous apportent pas grand chose,
vous n’avez pas à les suivre.
On ne va pas mettre de côté
les personnes,
il faut choisir ce qu’on veut dans la vie
et les gens qui nous font du bien.
Je ne vais pas dire qu’il  faut suivre
de comptes constructifs -
moi, sur les réseaux sociaux,
je n’aime pas trop suivre
de comptes constructifs,
comme les informations,
tout ce qui est très utile,
j’aime voir ça de temps en temps,
mais je veux passer du bon temps
sur les réseaux
parce que j’ai l’impression
que c’est un moment de détente.
Donc je vais suivre des comédiens,
des personnes qui me motivent.
Je vais suivre des personnes qui donnent
des conseils qui m’intéressent,
mais il faut quand même faire le tri,
ne pas suivre énormément de personnes,
parce chaque personne a sa vision,
chacun a sa manière
de voir les choses.
Je ne peux pas suivre tout le monde
et je ne peux pas consommer
le contenu de toutes ces personnes.
Donc, il faut quand même filtrer.
Il faut garder le strict minimum
pour ne pas se perdre ;
il y a quand même certaines personnes
qui n’ajoutent aucune valeur
à mon développement personnel.
Et ça varie d’une personne à une autre.
Mais on ne va pas juger Hadou -
il m’apporte peu de choses,
il ne chante pas bien.
Ce n’est pas pour catégoriser les gens,
c’est juste qu’il faut voir
ce qui me concerne,
ce qui va participer
à mon développement personnel,
pour que mon développement
à ma propre échelle soit bien.
Il faut savoir que nos choix rapides
peuvent avoir des conséquences
sur le long terme dans notre quotidien.
Alors décidez de ce que vous voulez
et de l’entourage que vous vous créez.
Si vous suivez des personnes
motivées et ambitieuses,
sachez que c’est une motivation
pour vous aussi.
Personnellement, quand je suis des gens
qui réussissent dans la vie,
je me dis :
« Pourquoi je reste sur mon téléphone ?
« Pourquoi je choisis de ne rien faire
plutôt que de poursuivre mes rêves ? »
Ça me motive de voir des gens
qui réussissent.
Ça me motive.
Mais ça dépend de chaque personne.
Quand je suis des personnes qui
alimentent trop la culture du vide -
parfois ça fait du bien
de regarder des vidéos
qui ne vont rien apporter à votre valeur
et à votre développement personnel,
mais c’est quand même bien
et très important
de suivre des gens qui vont
vous apporter quelque chose
du temps que vous passez sur les réseaux.